Olivia's got more details that what's
coming out of Ukraine specifically the
comments from those Ukrainian officials
I just want to add a little bit of
perspective to something here that
certainly has been part of the Ukraine
story over the last couple days and that
was the shoot-down of a Ukrainian
military transport plane a few days ago
the Ukrainians specifically accused the
Russians of playing a part in that the
Russians have denied that the reason
they cited that was the fact that that
plane was flying at 21,000 feet and only
sophisticated weapons could reach an
aircraft flying at that altitude this
plane assuming it was on a normal
commercial route over to a kuala lumpur
would have probably been in the range of
about 30,000 feet obviously we'll get
more details on that so just want to put
that in perspective the kind of weapon
that would need to be that would meet be
necessary here to target plane flying at
that altitude that's the United States
has not gone as far as to suggest the
Russians played a role specifically in
the downing of that Ukrainian military
transport but they have also made the
case or pointed out that a sophisticated
weapon was needed to target that
aircraft the question will be again what
kind of weapon brought this down what
were the circumstances here and of
course who fired the weapon sochi 14.jpg
what's going on